[Musik]
dort wo andere Ferien machen da arbeiten
wir wir sind die zdf-korrespondenten für
Österreich Britta Hilpert und Wolf
Christian Ulrich wir sehen seit Jahren
wie sich die Alpen verändern besonders
in dieser Saison Klimawandel
Gletscherschmelze Umweltstress
ich bin Skifahrerin und ich möchte
einfach nur weiter Skifahren das muss
doch möglich sein ich bin kein Skifahrer
und ich frage mich ob die Bergwelt nicht
ohnehin schon zu sehr gelitten hat steht
das Bergparadies auf der Kippe da kann
ich nicht weiter einfach jeden Hügeln
jede Fläche verbauen ich merke die
Auswirkungen ich will das eigentlich gar
nicht und trotzdem Reise er in diesem
Zirkus um die ganze Welt
wie geht Winterurlaub trotz Klimawandel
[Musik]
statt der Skisaison
der ehemalige corona-hotspot ist wieder
im Vollbetrieb
Krise ist hier kein Thema
im Gegenteil ja ich würde immer wieder
hinkommen also ich kann das nur Leute
empfehlen also hier ist es mega geil
schöne Atmos
phäre den Nachholbedarf also es ist
eigentlich so wie ein alten Zeiten wir
haben schon zu viele Krisen überstanden
auf 1.300 Metern
[Musik]
wer hier herkommt will Party und
Skifahren satt
[Musik]
wer hier herkommt will die Krisen
vergessen
im Skiparadies steckt viel Arbeit sie
feiern Schnee aus allen Rohren
Klimawandel macht Skifahren Energie
intensiver
die Gäste wollen schon zum Saisonstart
perfekte Pisten
was kostet der Spaß wie wirken da
Klimakrise Inflation und steigende
Energiepreise für einen Tag Ischgl gebe
ich aus 67 Euro für den Tagespass
Filme und 50 Euro für die Skiausrüstung
zwischen 130 und 530 Euro für das
Doppelzimmer pro Nacht
und für den snacker Berg zum Beispiel
eine Wurst 9,60 € und die ist ohne
Jägermeister wohl kaum zu verdauen
bei den Preisen haben die Gäste hohe
Erwartung und so geht nur ein bisschen
Energie sparen keine Sitzheizung im
Sessellift und gebremste Gondelfahrten
mehr will er den Gästen nicht zumuten
erzählt mir seilbahnchef Zange Ende
November arbeitet er noch mit Horror
Prognosen Preissteigerungen von 300 bis
über 700 Prozent und trotzdem an der
Beschneiung will er nicht sparen ein
Skibetrieb ohne Beschneidung der
funktioniert eigentlich nicht also wenn
ich jetzt so beschneihe dass der Gast
auch keine Komfort Einbußen hat das
hatte ich bezahle auch für den Skipass
auch erheblich mehr als noch im letzten
Jahr
der Strom für Gondeln und
pistenbescheiung in Ischgl entspricht
dem Verbrauch von
5.600 Haushalten
[Musik]
meist sei es Ökostrom sagt Zangerl aber
der Klimawandel die Energiepreise haben
auch seine Meinung geändert er kann sich
jetzt hier Photovoltaik vorstellen sogar
Windräder
[Musik]
auch in seiner Familie gibt es nun
Debatten über Umwelt und Klima und
wiederaufwand zu rechtfertigen sei
erzählt er
rechtfertigen kann man es damit dass
eigentlich natürlich wir brauchen
Energie das glaube ich kann auch gar
nicht in Abrede stellen wir sind ein
energieintensiv versektor nur muss man
schon auch sehen was mit diesen Aufwand
an Wertschöpfung in der Region
geschaffen wird
Seilbahnen und Schneekanonen geben in
Österreich 17.000 Menschen direkt Arbeit
sie verbrauchen dabei 0,3% des Stroms
relativ wenig sei das meinen Sie hier
auch weil Bergdörfer wie Ischgl ohne
Skitourismus wohl aussterben würden
Menschen im Tal bedeuten und auch in der
näheren Region bereiten dass sie die
Lebensgrundlage verlieren dass sie rein
hat gesagt auswandern müssten
doch der Klimawandel ist nun deutlich
spürbar diese Bilder gingen um die Welt
und eine Zahl
13 Pisten Tote zu Beginn dieser
schneearmen Saison ein Rekord
Skifahren ohne gut gepolsterte
schneepufferzonen ist gefährlich die
Winter kommen später und sind wärmer
seit den 60ern ist die Temperatur in den
Alpen um bis zu 2 Grad gestiegen
und je nach Mikroklima hat das sichtbare
Folgen für die Schneedecke
geht Skifahren doch im Klimawandel
es wird natürlich teurer werden dass das
dass das da steht außer Frage denke ich
aber ich würde es nicht verbieten wollen
also das wäre Unsinn es ist halt weniger
Schnee also man kann jetzt weniger
irgendwie Rampen oder sowas fahren weil
die halt einfach nicht da sind Sonntag
war ja noch nicht so viel Schnee da
haben wir
da muss man tatsächlich schon ein
bisschen anders fahren mit dem Kunst
Schnee ne
e gehört für viele einfach zum Winter
dazu manche lieben ihn so sehr sie
wollen darin übernachten
aber auch das schneehotel ist kein
Naturereignis erzählt mehr Michael
rothleitner auch dieser Schnee kommt aus
der Kanone die Projekte die ich jetzt
Schneekanonen hätten zu Unrecht den Ruf
Klimasünder zu sein sagt rotleitner er
ist beschneiungsberater ein Vergleich
soll zeigen die neuen sind
energiesparender
Effizienz muss sein allein schon weil
die Tage unter Null weniger werden dann
ist das Problem ja im Wesentlichen dass
die eigentlichen kalten
Zeiten in denen immer beschneiden kann
weniger werden und das bedeutet wenn man
effizient schneiden will dass man in
diesem kurzen Zeiten sehr viel Schnee
produzieren muss das können die neuen
ihre Motoren und Rotoren sind moderner
und so zeigen 20 Jahre Forschung Wirkung
mein brotleitner weniger ist die Hälfte
von der anderen Maschine das ist die
Entwicklung im Wesentlichen der 28 Jahre
der Energieverbrauch der Schneekanonen
Falle kaum ins Gewicht meint er sie
helfen mit dem Klimawandel umzugehen das
wo sie mit der Beschneiung ja vor allem
tun können ist eine verlässlichen
Saisonbeginn sicherstellen das heißt der
Gast kommt buchen der Koch einstellen
die einzelne Kanone braucht weniger
Energie aber man brauchte mal mehr von
ihnen um die 70% der Pisten werden
beschneid das kostet die Seilbahnen bis
zu 20% vom Umsatz
Touristiker seien mindestens finanziell
Leidtragende des Klimawandels aber nicht
nur gibt dazu natürlich sind sie da so
wie jeder von uns Täter ist also ich
glaube dass wir Europäer die
Nordamerikaner auch
uns einfach in klein sein müssen dass
unser Energieverbrauch
einfach nicht akzeptabel ist
meine auf 1200 Metern
geht Winterurlaub nur auf der Skipiste
fragen wir Manuela Mandel sie gehört zu
den weltweit erfolgreichsten Freeridern
[Musik]
sie meint die Alpen haben so viel mehr
zu bieten Winterurlaub geht auch ohne
Ski es ist muss nicht immer Skifahren
auf der Piste sein es gibt doch ganz
viele andere und Rodeln kann zu meinen
liebsten Freizeitbeschäftigungen
Manu Mandel gehört zu einer Gruppe von
Athleten die sich für mehr
Nachhaltigkeit und Klimaschutz im
Wintersport engagieren
protectore Winters weist die
Organisation verteidigt unsere Winter
und die Alpen ich bin sehr konservativ
was irgendwie Skigebiete Erweiterungen
oder Zusammenschlüsse betrifft also wir
glauben wir haben echt genug Struktur im
Alpenraum wir brauchen die Nummer mehr
alpine Freiräume sind ohnehin schon
angegriffen
so sieht es aus wenn neue Seilbahnen und
Hütten gebaut werden an anderen Stellen
sind es Wasserkraftwerke oder Speicher
Teiche der Bodenverbrauch auch für den
Wintersport ist riesig auch wenn es an
vielen Ecken noch wild aussieht kein
Gebirge der Welt hat so viel
Infrastruktur und Skigebiete wie die
Alpen
sind über 20 Skigebiete in Tirol sind
ich glaube knapp 100 Skigebiete in
Nordamerika hat mal ein Skigebiet und
dann fahrt man eineinhalb bis drei
Stunden und dann kommt das nächste
Skigebiet vielleicht deswegen ist es
umso wichtiger dass man halt bewusst mit
dem bestehenden Naturräumen umgeht
die Athleten von Protektor Winters
machen inzwischen internationaldruck sie
fordern Klimaschutz auch im Profisport
das schmelzende Polareis auf den
Skianzug gedruckt so machten US-Sportler
bei der Ski-WM auf den Klimawandel
aufmerksam kurz nach dem Wettbewerb
übergibt der österreichische
Skirennläufer Julian schütter von
Protector Winters eine Petition an die
fies mehr für den Klimaschutz zu tun der
Klimawandel bedroht unseren Sport
existenziell und akut und wenn man das
in den Griff gegangen ähm gibt's unseren
Sport einfach
über 400 Athleten haben unterschrieben
die klimaschutzdiskussion ist mitten im
Profisport angekommen
die größten Emissionen im Ski Weltcups
sind eindeutig Reise Emissionen
die Kills zu reduzieren
dass man für die Wettbewerbe mehrmals in
der Saison zwischen Nordamerika und
Europa hin und her fliegen müssen sich
organisatorisch vermeiden sagen die
Sportler doch solche Diskussionen möchte
die fies hier nicht öffentlich führen
können
vielen Dank danke schön am Ende erbarmt
sich die kommunikationschefin
zurück in Mallnitz hier hat das Umdenken
schon vor Jahren eingesetzt wie kann ein
ganzer Skiort nachhaltig werden weniger
Schnee weniger halb weniger Gäste das
ist hier die Herausforderung erzählt
Peter Angermann vom österreichischen
Alpenverein
weil es gilt ja als die Wiege des
Alpinismus das ist da hinten der Ankogel
der ist 3250 m hoch der ist 1762 das
erste Mal von einem Bauern aus dem
Gasteinertal außer die bionistischen
Motiven bestiegen worden
in den 70ern war in Mallnitz noch groß
was los so feierte Kärnten den abrissi
doch irgendwann zogen die Gäste in
andere Skigebiete die noch mehr Party
und pistenboten und in Mainz wurde es
still
die Antwort auf die Krise fand Peter
Angermann als Tourismusdirektor erfand
er das Konzept vom Bergsteigerdorf
sanfte Tourismus als Zukunftsmodell
große Infrastruktur Hotel Infrastruktur
somit 3 ist der Bergsteiger der Verein
Logo
außerdem ist der öffentliche Nahverkehr
für die Gäste kostenlos und man heizt
mit einem eigenen biokraftwerk
vor allem aber wird meine Netz für die
Anreise mit dem Zug denn beim
CO2-Fußabdruck im Winterurlaub entfallen
rund 70 Prozent allein auf die an- und
Abreise wer zum Beispiel von Mainz nach
mainitz fährt erzeugt mit dem Flugzeug
269 kg CO2 mit dem Auto 140 mit der Bahn
dagegen nur rund 50 Kilogramm CO2
[Musik]
durch die Warnungen vor dem Klimawandel
fangen Leute wirklich an zu denken die
Kinder sagen den Leuten schon den Eltern
das war ja mal nicht fliegen und das war
ja mal mit der Bahn fahren auf Urlaub
mit dem IC direkt auf die Piste so
reisen hier aber immer noch wenige
gegessen
ich konnte das Klima die geht nur
empfehlen es ist viel besser mit dem Zug
zu fahren mit dem Auto
zwei Stunden später hat der Bahn Freund
zunächst ein Date mit einem Lama und
dann mit einem kühlen Bier
[Musik]
Stefanie grischnick übernahm die
stockerhütte in Mainz von ihren Eltern
wenn sie nicht gar den rauen Mengen
Kaiserschmarren verteilt bietet sie
lamawanderungen für die Touristen an
[Musik]
für den Ort ist jetzt nicht gleich
Skifahren gibt sondern auch Alternativen
eben bis rodendes
dabei sein
echt österreichische Lamas begleiten die
Touristen durchs Tauern Tal es gibt
Abwechslung in den Alpen diese
mallnitz-botschaft hat auch Familie
zebitz aus Berlin Spandau erreicht
Fahrer hat und deswegen heißt sich das
immer so die Waage dass man auch
wirklich sagt man geht man Skifahren
oder wie gehen Skifahren und er macht
was anderes und deswegen haben wir uns
genau das hier ausgesucht weil so viele
Möglichkeiten gibt es nicht Skifahrer
auch was zu machen
Seefeld in Tirol auf knapp 1200 m
snow farming nennt man das
den Schnee vom letzten Jahr haben sie
über den Sommer gelagert nun hilft er
Leuten zu schaffen
ohne das wäre auch sie kaum hier Laura
Dahlmeier kommt mit dem hybridaus
Garmisch die knappe Stunde zum Training
herüber
eigentlich gilt das Seefelder
Hochplateau als schneesicher doch jetzt
kurz nach Weihnachten sind nur zwei von
20 Leuten geöffnet beide nur dank snow
farming und Schneekanonen mittlerweile
ist es leider relativ normal aber das
ist so wenig Schnee hat damit hätte
jetzt auch nicht gerechnet vor allen
Dingen wir hatten ja mal Schnee aber
jetzt ist er halt wieder weg
seit Jahren beobachtet sie wie der
Schnee immer später kommt und immer
schneller wieder weg ist und damit die
Grundlage für Ihren Erfolg als Athletin
schon früh drehte sich bei ihr alles um
Biathlon vielleicht im Weltcup das sind
halt so meine Ziele und so
2017 gelingt ihr das und noch mehr
fünfmal Gold einmal Silber bei der WM
und der Gesamtweltcup Sieg
2018 erringt sie olympisches Gold gleich
zwei Mal
Laura Dahlmeier ist eine der
erfolgreichsten deutschen Biathletinnen
überhaupt
ein Star entschied Zirkus eine
nachdenkliche Athletin die für viele
spricht
ich merke die Auswirkungen dieser
Klimaveränderung ich will das eigentlich
gar nicht und trotzdem Reise sie ja in
diesem Zirkus um die ganze Welt und ihm
will ja aber eigentlich was gutes für
die Umwelt für Klima und darum Leben die
uns am Zwiespalt
[Applaus]
seit sie 2019 den aktiven Wettkampfsport
beendete engagiert sie sich mehr gegen
den Klimawandel
denn auch im Sommer beim Bergsteigen
merkt sie wie sich die Berge ändern
[Musik]
und das war echt schwierig da im Juni
überhaupt noch Eis zu finden wir haben
echt weit drauf gehen müssen wenn wir
andere Regionen anschauen da ist eben
einfach unten gar kein Gletscher mehr
Natur bewahren und genießen wollen alle
doch hinfahren wollen sie auch wenn
jeder kleine Schritte macht dann hilft
das schon meint Laura Dahlmeier doch der
Zwiespalt bleibt ich gehe gern
Langlaufen ich gehe gern Skifahren ich
mache gern Skitouren die Eisklettern und
dafür braucht es kalte Temperaturen und
dann Schnee und wenn der von Haus aus
von Natur einfach nicht mehr da ist ja
dann greift die Industrie da ein und es
ist natürlich ein riesen Sektor und es
steckt sehr sehr viel Geld dahinter also
denke immer versucht das ganze System so
lange wie möglich aufrecht zu erhalten
Klimaschutz und Skifahren beides muss
möglich sein meint Laura Dahlmeier es
ist hier leben und das viele Menschen
in Österreich hängen von der
Skiindustrie 10.000er Arbeitsplätze ab
bei Fischer Ski sind es 560
Franz Föttinger zeigt mir die Bretter
die seine Welt bedeuten vom frühen Ski
aus einem Holzstück der 30er bis zu
Franz klammers C4 competition
nationales Ereignis würde ich sagen ja
und die Absatzmärkte waren entsprechend
aber
merkte aber mehr als doppelt so groß als
global als muss heute haben
früher hatte man eher ein eigenes paar
das wollen sich heute viele nicht mehr
leisten warme Winter kommen noch dazu
erzählter besonders Langlaufski
bleibender im Lager der Absatz insgesamt
stagniert Inflation Corona Fachkräfte
Klimakrise was bestimmt seine Strategie
am meisten
langfristig ist es natürlich die
Klimaerwärmung die für unseren Thema ist
wenn es wärmer wird wird
Skifahren oder Sport auf Schnee
natürlich zum Thema oder wird
schwieriger und wir gehen schon davon
aus dass wir auch die nächsten 20 30
Jahre noch sehr gute Winter erleben
werden auch im Europa aber der
langfristige Trend ist natürlich dass es
wärmer werden
Seefeld hat man sich darauf schon
eingestellt die Seele des Hauses ist
Elisabeth Gürtler dann haben wir
natürlich jetzt hier auch eine ganz
tolle schmuckerstellung
Elisabeth Gürtler ist elegant
detailversessen
und penibel
[Musik]
sie ist eine grandam und wie das Hotel
Sacher eine österreichische Institution
bei ihr sind die großen zu Gast erholen
sich von den Krisen der Welt und die
Krisen beeindrucken das Luxussegment
kaum erklärt sie mir
[Musik]
dass sie nicht viele Gäste deswegen
manche die ohnehin schon eher die immer
die einfache zimmerkette Regel genommen
haben damit sie nicht so viel zahlen für
das Wohnen aber trotzdem alle
Annehmlichkeiten haben und den Spar
haben
4.500 Quadratmeter Wellness 32 Grad
innen Temperatur 6 Millionen Euro
kostete kürzlich die Verdoppelung des
barbereichs
ihre Gäste kommen vor allem hier für die
Schneelage draußen kümmert wenig Service
ist wichtiger
Fachkräfte ist sicher dass alle größte
Problem man muss natürlich auch die
Preise anheben wir haben sie insgesamt
seit einem Jahr am 15% angehoben weil
die Personalkosten höher geworden sind
wir kriegen gute Leute nur noch
mitzuhören Gehälter aber auch weil die
Energiepreise unfassbar gestiegen sind
das Sacher spart leere Zimmer bleiben
ungeheizt einer von vier Außenpools ist
zu
glauben
die Erwartung sind so exklusiv wie die
Preise weiß Elisabeth Gürtler das
Ehepaar malzström aus Berlin gehört noch
zu den die Verständnis haben wir sitzen
ja alle mitten in dieser Energie oder
nicht nur Energiekrise auch aber auch in
der sonstigen Krise und ich wäre aber
auch bereit das hinzunehmen und wenn der
Service kleiner wird dann ist das so
glauben sie alle Gäste denken nein das
glaube ich nicht
im Urlaub fällt es wohl jedem schwer auf
angenehmes zu verzichten
und Franz Hörl gehört zu denen die
meinen dass das keiner muss der
einflussreiche konservative Politiker
meint der Wintertourismus sei das Herz
der österreichischen Wirtschaft
ist unsere Produktionsfläche und keine
spricht über die dritte vierte
fabrikzeile aber alle sprechen über
Pisten
Skifahren sei kein Klimakiller meint er
der Strom dafür käme zudem meist aus
Wasserkraft die Wintersaison verbraucht
2780 Gigawattstunden das sind 0,9% des
österreichischen Stroms das mache doch
im Klimawandel keinen großen Unterschied
nach unseren
Prognosen fahren wir im Jahr 2050
genauso wie heute es werden es wird sich
die Schneefallgrenze um ungefähr 200
Höhenmeter verschieben das haben wir
locker im Griff
weiter so
ist Eberstein im Kärnten auf 580 m
heute reden alle vom Klimaschutz das
biolandhaus Arche in Kärnten macht schon
seit knapp 40 Jahren vor wie das auch im
Winterurlaub geht willkommen in
Österreichs erstem Öko-Hotel
Gott Vater gut Sohn Geist er Segen in
dieses Haus und alle die den hier ein
und aus mögen wir ein gesundes
erfolgreiches
liebesvolles Jahr leben
das wird immer Tessmann segnet sein
Hotel für die Gäste und für die
Wintersaison
[Musik]
stolz zeigt er uns sein Haus
das ist jetzt quasi ein lehmbauzimmer
lehm ist der beste Baustoff überhaupt
sozusagen es speichert sehr gut die
Luftfeuchtigkeit und gibt sie sehr
langsam in den Raum wieder ab
Holz dass das atmet ja auch es gibt es
es reduziert einen Herzschlag und
schläft besser
seit Ende der 80er geht's hier schon
eine Solaranlage bei Schnee hilft
regionale Ökoenergie
was heute Trend ist hatten die tessmanns
schon damals im Blick und da sieht man
so ein Bild Entstehung des Hauses
das ist ein besonderer Moment gewesen
hier ne ja also wir sind das erste Hotel
in Österreich dass ein Umweltzeichen
bekommen hat das österreichische
unbezeichnung mit der Nummer 0 0 1 und
darüber sind also bis heute doch noch
stolz
wir haben noch eine Aufgabe zu erfüllen
dass die Region
lebenswert und lebenswürdig und du
lebensfähig bleibt
in der Küche kochen sie vegetarisch
es war eine grundsätzliche meiner Mutter
vor fast 40 Jahren
ja da waren wir ziemlich die ersten also
was sie man hat sich einiges anhören
müssen vom körndlfresser bis bis wie
eine Leute überhaupt satt und so weiter
und heute sieht man in der Klima
Diskussion dass natürlich ganz ganz
wichtig ist dass wir uns wieder mehr
vegetarisch ernähren
denn kein Fleisch bedeutet deutlich
weniger CO2 die Gäste kommen deshalb
ist es seit 30 Jahren kein Fleisch und
ich finde kein Hotel so wie dieses wo
man so gut verköstigt wird ein Klima
bewusstes Hotel darauf legen die Gäste
großen Wert manche sind von weit her mit
dem Zug angereist
fordern schon 12 Stunden mit dem Zug bis
ich hier bin und der Schweiz durch den
Vorarlberg zu fahren das hat auch schon
ferienqualität sage ich jetzt mal da
der CO2-Fußabdruck einer Hotel
Übernachtung berechnet sich unter
anderem aus dem Energieverbrauch des
Hotels Wäsche Wasser Abfall und
natürlich dem Lebensmittelangebot
in einem normalen Hotel verbraucht ein
gastgrund 19 kg CO2 pro Tag im
biolandhaus Arche dagegen nur
sechseinhalb das ist in Österreich
rekordverdächtig wenig und hat sich
herumgesprochen
auch bei den Heilpraktikerinnen die hier
in der Schneelandschaft ein Seminar
abhalten sie suchen Heilung und Kraft
[Musik]
hier ist es abgelegen es ist still und
es geht um sein nicht der Action
hier wir dürfen wirklich in dich Hingabe
kommen in dem sein und Raum geben zum
runterfahren ja und das ist heißer es
tut sehr gut
das solche Seminare gleich wochenweise
Zimmer buchen kommt Tessmann zu Bass
auch er spürt die Aufenthaltsdauer der
Gäste sank wie in ganz Österreich von
5,2 auf 3,6 Tage
was für 14 Tage waren sind jetzt zehn
Tage was vor fünf Tage waren sind jetzt
drei Tage die Seminare bescheren ihm
darüber hinaus dass ganze Jahr über
Gäste unabhängig von der Saison und das
ist für viele Hotels der Knackpunkt
überleben ohne Schnee die Seminare sind
gut planbar
40% der Umsätze gehen bereits in diesen
Seminarbereich hinein und wie gesagt ich
schaffe es mittlerweile es über das
ganze Jahr zu verteilen das Öko-Hotel
hat einen Unique Selling Point es ist
klimafreundlich und wird so von der
Skisaison unabhängig
geißau Hintersee auf 740 Metern
das Hunde rennen war schon drei Wochen
zuvor geplant doch erst jetzt liegt
genügend Schnee in Hintersee
für das 450 Seelendorf ein Großereignis
dem Zieleinlauf treffe ich Albert Ebner
und Rosi und Franz Kloiber die beiden
sind Hobby Meteorologen seit Jahrzehnten
macht ihre Familie Wetteraufzeichnungen
[Musik]
länger Schnee bis im Mai eine wir machen
das jetzt über 25 Jahre und was man
feststellen kann bei uns hier in
Hintersee ist dass sich auf die Klima
werden Erwärmung insofern auswirkt dass
die Temperaturen nach oben gehen und
sich die neue Stimmungen leider doch
verringern
es braucht nun solche Events meinte
Albert Ebner ihm gehört das einzige
Hotel am Ort der Schnee ist zu
unzuverlässig und die Gäste hierher zu
locken auch seine Familie hatte einige
Klimawandel Krisensitzungen erzählte
machen wir den Betrieb kleiner oder oder
investieren wir werden immer größer und
das sind gegen den Tränke geschwommen
und haben gesagt wir versuchen es wir
probieren es wir haben ein Konzept
dahinter und das hilft
so eine event
denn die acht Lifte des Skigebietes
stehen seit dieser Saison steht
Missmanagement und Klimawandel machten
den Betrieb unwirtschaftlich
[Musik]
in der Region haben einige die
Konsequenzen gezogen das Hotel Alte Post
ist geschlossen der Winter machte sogar
minus der Sommer konnte es kaum
ausgleichen Schluss nach 300 Jahren
bei Albert Ebner hingegen Hochbetrieb am
Hunderennen Tag die ganze Familie packt
mit an ohne ihren Segen hätte er wohl
nicht investiert erzählte
die Summe will er nicht nennen es sind
wohl Millionen für Chalets mit Sauna und
Tiefgarage er sitzt jetzt auf
Ganzjahresbetrieb auf mit oder ohne
Schnee
er hofft dass er sich noch rechtzeitig
umgestellt hat
wir gehen davon aus dass wir hier
unser jahresangebot mit Skifahren und
auch ohne Skifahren machen können aber
es wird sicher auch Skigebiete geben die
wahrscheinlich aufhören und in dieser
Lage sind wo man nicht weiß kommt
schnell kommt nicht und das ist
natürlich schwierig dieses zu
kalkulieren also muss man sich in eine
andere Richtung bewegen die Zahl der
schneesicheren Skigebiete singt in
Österreichs Alpen 2007 waren es noch 200
bei bis zu zwei Grad Erwärmung bleiben
wohl nur
115 bei bis zu vier Grad Erwärmung nur
noch 47
[Musik]
wenn Schnee liegt verleiht Albert
Tourenski wenn nicht bietet der
Fahrräder an vielleicht so hofft er
läuft der Lift noch mal aber zentral ist
der nicht mehr
ja war früher zentral ja aber wird in
Zukunft wenn ich mir das Modell von mir
so vorstelle wird es wahrscheinlich ein
Teil unseres gesamtes Angebots über das
ganze Jahr sein werden ja da ist wie man
sagt im Fachjargon werden wahrscheinlich
bei uns durch den Klimawandel weniger
werden also von 110 gehe ich einmal
davon aus dass es ja das wird zwischen
60 und 80 90 Tage sich einwandeln
Lüfte rentieren sich erst wenn sie mehr
als 100 Tage laufen Hintersee muss also
erstmal ohne klarkommen und ich auch
früh geht es auf den Berg ohne Lift mit
Anita bitterlich und Gerd Frühwirt vom
Salzburger Alpenverein sie sind perfekt
ausgerüstet
was ist das ein LVS das ist die
Abkürzung für Lawinen verschütteten
Suchgerät und das haben wir hatten immer
dabei wenn man sich im freien Gelände
bewegt
vorsicht ist geboten meint sie auch wenn
wir die alte Piste hochgehen
von weiter oben sieht man Deutschland
und einen Gletscher der nicht mehr ist
unterhalb dieser drei Gipfel und das
sieht man eine Spitze das ist die die
Watzmann Jungfrau da ist das watzmannka
und am Schluss dieses Chaos war ein
Gletscher der in den letzten Jahren
Jahrzehnten abgeschmolzen ist die
Zeitfenster werden immer knapper wo man
wirklich gut Skifahren kann wir haben
uns einfach darauf eingestellt wir
fahren dann wenn es geht
[Musik]
Tourenski ist im Trend
Pause auf der Latschen Alm mit
Schneeschuhen kam Winfried Herbst vom
Naturschutzbund her das warme Wetter ist
ein heißes Thema Winfried meint der
Mensch belastet die Alpen insgesamt
schon zu viel ich glaube wir sind schon
über die Grenzen gegangen die uns gut
tun und die uns im Gebirge und unsere
Saison in der geißau funktioniert dass
dadurch ein kleines Skigebiet zusperren
muss für den
Skitourengeher Raum geschaffen wird dann
begrüße ich das
jeder will was Eigenes von den Bergen
Touren Ski Alpin naturidee das wird hier
klar nur eines fehlt ein gemeinsamer Weg
es gibt eigentlich nie die Überlegung
dass man sich zusammensetzt wohin wollen
wir denn ist das eine gute Entwicklung
auch wenn
alternative Energien eingesetzt werden
für Lifte in die man Windräder baut und
so weiter
Lüfte verschönern keine Berge nun werden
auch Windkrafträder gebaut um sie zu
betreiben
es bleibt ein schwieriger Weg zum
umweltfreundlichen Skitourismus für
jedermann und er wird wohl kein so
schönes Ende finden wie unsere Tour
Skitouren werden wohl nie ein
Massensport es war anstrengend aber es
war schön ich kann es empfehlen
wenn man dann oben ist hat man sich den
Berg auch erarbeitet genau man ist
richtig stolz und zufrieden ja man hat
es geschafft und darf sich auf die
Abfahrt freuen genau
weniger ist mehr erlebe ich hier die
eine Abfahrt ist dann eben besonders
schön
[Musik]
Sulden im italienischen Südtirol auf
1906 Metern direkt am Fuß des Ortlers
besuchen wir Reinhold Messner
die JAX im Hof erinnern ein große
Abenteuer im Himalaya messen ist Legende
der Bergsteiger kämpft seit Jahrzehnten
für einen respektvollen Tourismus in den
Alpen die schönsten Stellen in Südtirol
sind nicht mehr ansehnlich weil einfach
da hunderte von Leuten täglich sind die
nur den Landschaft fotografieren und
landen glauben damit die Landschaft
mitgenommen zu haben die jungen Leute
kommen in die alten aber sie wollten
Fall haben sie wollen den Kick haben
aber nicht die
nachhaltige Form des Erlebens der Natur
Messners Mantra Reduktion mit wenigen
Hilfsmitteln höchste Gipfel erklimmen
[Musik]
diese Reduktion aufs Wesentliche fordert
Messner auch für den Tourismus in den
Alpen in unzähligen Vorträgen und
Büchern
ich würde Ihnen gerne aus ihrem Buch
vorlesen rettet die alten vor 20 Jahren
geschrieben auf eine weitere
Erschließung der hochgebirgsregion für
das reine Freizeitvergnügen Skifahren
Wandern Biken und klettern muss
verzichtet werden würden sie es heute
noch mal genauso sagen also ich würde
dafür da holen genauso die wichtigen
Sachen die wir jetzt zu bewältigen haben
in den Alpen ist die Verteilung unserer
Gäste
wir haben an einigen Stellen viel zu
viele an anderen Stellen zu wenige hier
sind es gerade zu viele Rush Hour im
zwei Stunden entfernten golden einer der
bekanntesten Skiorte von Südtirol ohne
ihn wäre hier längst das Chaos
ausgebrochen
schwerer Verkehr obwohl der öffentliche
Nahverkehr für die Hotelgäste kostenlos
ist mehr geht nicht mehr deshalb hat
Südtirol jetzt einen bettenstopp nur
noch in Ausnahmefällen sollen neue
Hotelbetten genehmigt werden
Nils Demetz Sprecher der Grödner
Hoteliers findet das in Ordnung
es wäre in Gröden arbeiten schon lange
in einer Strategie eben um den Tourismus
richtig nachhaltig zu gestalten und da
gehört natürlich auch die Frage dazu wie
viel ist tragbar und wie viel soll noch
dazu kommen mit dem richtigen
Verwöhnprogramm und genug Abwechslung
seien die Hotels das ganze Jahr über
ausgelastet die Gäste bleiben im Schnitt
5 Tage also recht lang das ist insgesamt
nachhaltig bedeutet aber auch der
Winterurlaub wird exklusiver heißt
teurer
Exklusivität ist sicher eine nachhaltige
Schiene weil Quantität im begrenzt ist
und ich denke auch dass wir eben über
diese Exklusivität in Zukunft eben das
Wachstum erzielen müssen und werden auch
und natürlich jetzt die eine oder andere
Preissteigerung bringen und auch
brauchen aber ich glaube im Grunde
profitieren dann alle davon Gäste die
einheimische Bevölkerung eben und auch
die Wirtschaft treibende
macht die Gegend für junge einheimische
unbezahlbar im Nachbardorf ST kassian
sehen wir edle Neubauten teure
Ferienwohnungen für die betuchten keine
Zukunftslösung meint grünen Politikerin
Elite mußner
die Immobilienpreise steigen sind in den
Sternen mit über 10.000 Euro pro
Quadratmeter die Touristen sind von
außen die ins Tal kommen die investieren
auch gerne hier bei uns aber dann
entsteht diese Entfremdung zwischen
lokaler Gesellschaft lokaler Bevölkerung
und den Touristen wer hier aufwächst
kann finanziell oft nicht mithalten und
zieht weg ohne Touristen sei im Ort
inzwischen Toten Stille in der
Nebensaison da passiert gar nichts also
das sind zum Beispiel auch der Visan
kassian könnte man sagen ausgestorben
[Musik]
mehr los ist dagegen auf der Piste
dieser slong gehört zu den weltweit
bekanntesten weltcup-pisten hier wollen
sie 2029 die Ski-WM abhalten direkt am
Langkofel
[Musik]
unterwegs mit reiner saisona einen der
profiliertesten Rennleiter im Skizirkus
und treibende Kraft hinter der
wm-kandidatur
was hier kommt ist einfach das ist ein
Umbau hier wollen wir die ganzen
medienstrukturen reinbauen hier
unterirdisch sollen auch Parkplätze im
Sommer Grün im Winter Schnee weiß und
die Haut verschwinden
will eine nachhaltige WM bieten und
damit Zeichen setzen
wir sehen ja tagtäglich auch unsere
Verkehrsprobleme die Leute sollen von
den Hotels direkt mit den Fahnen zu
unserem Rennen kommen und dann nachdem
sie doch fertig haben von dort wieder
zurück mit den Skiern in die Hotels
Gröden hat eine große WM-Geschichte
manche erinnert sich noch an 1970 als
hier eine gewisse Rosi Mittermeier
durchstartet
wo sie Mittermeier aus Reit im Winkl
trainiert seit gestern wieder
ein Fernsehzentrum bietet in zwei
Studios mehr als so mancher deutscher
Reporter von zu Hause gewählt ist
das perfekte wintersport-event wollen
sie jetzt in grün schlagendes Argument
in Zeiten des Klimawandels eine
schneesichere Piste
wir stehen hier auf
2250 Meter wir sind sehr hoch und
deshalb das können Sie uns die nächsten
Jahre die nächsten Jahrzehnte retten
Kosten Klima Umweltschutz bei große
Sport-Events längst kritisch beugt
werden erklärte sie so na die
Nachhaltigkeit zu moralischen Pflicht so
sein Pisten und Infrastruktur ja seit
Jahren schon vorhanden wir haben ja
alles wir haben die Liste wir haben
alles und deshalb das ist für uns
nachhaltig
Elite mußner sieht das völlig anders sie
hat dafür gesorgt dass sich ihre
Gemeinde nicht an der wm-kandidatur
beteiligt
wir sind da in einem sehr guten Beispiel
von Greenwashing würde ich sagen denn
auf einer Seite wird man mit
Nachhaltigkeit aber man hat einfach nur
nicht verstanden dass eine
Massenveranstaltung mit Nachhaltigkeit
gar nichts zu tun hat aber wie geht
Skitourismus nachhaltig Gröden
funktioniert das ganze Jahr über
begrenzt die Betten will Qualität statt
Quantität und eine nachhaltige Ski WM
Elite Muster reicht das nicht sie
fordert eine andere Haltung zum nach
Urlaub
die Menschen kamen vor 100 Jahren oder
vor 50 Jahren im Garten einfach nur um
zu wandern wieso geht das heute nicht
mehr wieso braucht man Downhill für
Mountainbikes man braucht Skipisten im
Winter kann man einfach die Natur
genießen auch ohne Infrastruktur
vielleicht weil viele das so wollen die
Unterhaltung das Adrenalin den Schnee
in Zukunft meinen Experten profitieren
nur noch die größten und höchsten
Skigebiete die anderen kämpfen ums
blanke Überleben Reinhold Messner meint
die Gäste haben es jetzt in der Hand
verlängere Aufenthalt im Gebirge wäre
ein Schlüssel zum sauberen Tourismus das
Wandern ist die ideale Möglichkeit sich
zu erholen sich
ins Gebirge hinein zu begeben denn nur
in der Geschwindigkeit des Fußgängers
kann ich die Anstrengung verstehen kann
ich den Berg plötzlich einigermaßen
abschätzen wie groß da ist
[Musik]
ich bin überzeugt davon dass der alten
Tourismus nicht sterben wird im
Gegenteil
er wird sogar noch wachsen wenn wir
Angebote schaffen die nicht auf Kick aus
sind sondern auf Nachhaltigkeit
diese Skisaison hat alle aufgeschreckt
der Klimawandel verändert die Berge den
Wintersport
und den Tourismus
es gibt kein weiter so es wird weniger
Skigebiete geben und die die
weitermachen werden teurer
[Musik]
am Ende entscheiden die Gäste wie sie
die Alpen erleben wollen
[Musik]
und ob sie die Berge in Zukunft so
nehmen wie sie sind
großartig und unberechenbar
[Musik]